so our community is going to continue to
honor fallen nhp trooper micah may today
the injured police officers fund is
teaming up with nhp to hold a donation
drive at nevada coin mart it's off jones
and flamingo it's happening until 2 p.m
this afternoon
memorial t-shirts and face masks will be
on sale with all the benefits going to
trooper may's family
the injured police officers fund says
it's a privilege to be a part of a
community that really rallies around
people in their time of need
it's such an emotional time and this job
with this non-profit never gets easier
but it you just can't help but be so
grateful to be part of this family this
thin blue line family this las vegas
family this this family with the state
of nevada
i've never lived anywhere else but i can
tell you that i bet other cities aren't
like this
if you can't make it out to the donation
drive today and still want to donate you
can either buy mail check or online at
ipof.vegas
we have those details on 8newsnow.com